TWO HOURS, HA THE PILOT ASKED
PASSENGERS TO PRAY TWICE.
"EARLY START" ANCHOR DAVE BRIGGS
HAS MORE ON THIS TERRIFYING
FLIGHT.
>> FRIGHTENING MOMENTS ABOARD AN
AIRASIA X FLIGHT, VIOLENTLY
SHAKING MID FLIGHT OVER THE
INDIAN OCEAN.
THE AIRBUS A-330 HEADING TO
MALASIA WAS FORCED TO RETURN TO
AUSTRALIA AFTER ENGINE TROUBLE.
ABOUT 90 MINUTES LATER,
PASSENGERS SAY THEY HEARD A LOUD
BANG.
>> THE PASSENGER SAID ONE OF THE
BLADES ON THE LEFT ENGINE WAS
MISSING.
>> THE FLIGHT SHUTTERED FOR
NEARLY TWO HOURS, MANY SAYING IT
FELT LIKE BEING INSIDE A WASHING
MACHINE.
>> THE PLANE WAS REALLY, REALLY,
SHAUTERRING, SHUTTERING,
SHUTTERING.
>> Reporter: THE PILOT TELLING
PASSENGERS HE WAS SCARED AND
ASKING THEM TWICE TO PRAY.
>> LISTEN TO EVERYONE.
OUR SHOOIFL DEPENDS ON YOUR
COOPERATING.
>> Reporter: SOME PUTTING ON A
BRAVE FACE, OTHERS FEARING THE
WORST.
>> LOTS OF PEOPLE CRYING,
PULLING OUT LIFEJACKETS, PRETTY
MUCH PREPARING.
WE THOUGHT THERE WAS A GOOD
CHANCE WE WOULD GO DOWN.
>> Reporter: MARINE EMERGENCY
SERVICES STANDING BY FOR A WATER
RESCUE.
PASSENGERS BREATHING A SIGH OF
RELIEF ONCE THE PLANE TOUCHED
DOWN SAFELY BEFORE WAITING HOURS
FOR ANOTHER FLIGHT.
THE